spider-man no way home is probably one
of the best superhero movies to come out
in a long time but it has a big flaw
that could actually make it hard to
watch for some people and before you
start getting angry saying it's the best
film in the mcu since end game i kind of
agree with you it just also has a huge
whopping flaw
it's not a spider-man movie welcome back
to stream in the galaxy i'm rocket riley
and spider-man no way home was just
released and while i absolutely loved
the movie there was one massive problem
with it that's almost impossible to
ignore it's not really a spider-man
movie you're probably wondering what i
mean by that so i'll explain also if you
haven't seen the movie feel free to keep
watching i'll be sure to give you plenty
of warning before any spoilers are
mentioned first let's get into what was
good about the movie no way home is
probably one of the most fun movies
marvel's released since thor ragnarok it
carries all the light-heartedness of the
guardians of the galaxy films while also
having heart-wrenching moments that
rival even tony stark's death and end
game also tom holland finally reaches
his full acting potential and no way
home in the first two installments of
his franchise tom holland's performance
seemed to fall flat here though we get
to see the award-winning actor truly
show what he's capable of in both
action-packed and dramatic scenes
although no way home had plenty to love
there were a few things that held the
film back the first thing that seemed
off about the movie was the inclusion of
so many different villains as we saw in
the trailers it seemed like the villains
almost rounding out the sinister six
were simply added to the movie for
fanfare and none of them got the time
that they truly deserved and needed for
deeper character development and growth
in particular sandman and the lizard
were completely unnecessary if those two
weren't in the film it likely wouldn't
change a single thing now here come the
spoilers so skip to the time stamp on
your screen if you haven't seen
spiderman no way home
the biggest problem with no way home is
that instead of a spider-man movie we
got a massive crossover event spider-man
seems to be just one piece of a much
larger puzzle rather than his own unique
character although i was absolutely
stunned and delighted to see tobey
maguire and andrew garfield their
inclusion along with the continual
reminders that spider-man is simply one
of many superheroes just disconnects us
from what we should expect from a true
spider-man movie instead of a personal
intimate spider-man film we got a movie
that one could argue is a bigger
crossover than avengers in-game while
this may not be a bad thing it certainly
isn't what someone would expect going
into a movie with spider-man in the
title with all that said i still
thoroughly enjoyed seeing characters
come together from spider-man movies
spanning over almost two decades there
was also a pretty big plot hole that
wasn't explained and it made it a bit
hard to watch the movie peter's main
goal throughout the film was to fix the
villains and send them back to their own
universes the issue though is that after
peter fixes them he sends them back to
moments immediately before their deaths
norman osborne or green goblin has his
dual personality issues fixed and is
sent back to the moment before he gets
impaled by his own glider
doc ock has his neural link with the ai
controlled arms fixed and he gets sent
back to the moment right before he
drowns in the east river
so while peter is doing all this to try
to save their lives he failed to think
things through although he fixed them
peter sent each of the previously
villainous individuals straight to their
deaths even if strange altered the spell
to send them back to a time long before
the moment they entered the multiverse
so they could prevent their impending
deaths the tobey maguire and andrew
garfield films would no longer matter
this would essentially erase all of the
great stories we saw in these films
basically making them pointless either
way this simple plothole makes the main
objective of the movie meaningless and
may retcon the entirety of the maguire
in garfield spider-man films now just a
couple of little things i noticed about
the film that could have been fixed with
some minor tweaks
first of all they seem to gloss over how
peter got away with the events in london
after the incriminating video of
mysterio was released
also the huge detail that matt murdock
is finally confirmed to be in the mcu
was diminished to just a single scene he
was just overshadowed by the
increasingly large number of villains
that appeared in the film many people
complained that there were too many
villains in sam raimi's spider-man 3 but
this movie definitely takes the cake the
next thing i noticed was the fact that
so many crazy terrible things were going
on in new york and none of the avengers
showed up to help other than doctor
strange i understand that a lot of them
are tied up doing their own things some
of them off world but it seems like they
almost purposely didn't want to help
peter out j jonah jameson also seemed to
be added simply for fanservice but i
actually appreciated this it was nice to
see jameson again but he seemed a bit
more reserved and gentler than he was in
his original franchise i'd also hope to
see a bigger mention or cameo of miles
morales in the film while electro teased
mile's appearance saying he expected
spider-man to be black we didn't
actually get to see him electro's
comment could hint at miles eventual
inclusion in the mcu however lastly no
way home was pretty dark for the mcu
there were several scenes which not only
made the audience misty-eyed but some
which could almost scare you
for example the scene where tom
holland's peter nearly killed at norman
osborne was one of the darkest mcu
scenes we've ever seen calling back to
the incident where john walker smashed
in the head of a flag smasher with the
captain america shield also mae's death
scene in nowhere home rivaled some of
the saddest scenes featured in mcu
movies while it doesn't seem to fit in
perfectly with the rest of the mcu
catalog the film's dark tone does tie
into the upcoming mcu title doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
which was actually teased in the after
credits scene for no way home according
to kevin feige the multiverse of madness
will be the closest thing to a horror
film we'll get to see in the mcu so the
somewhat darker tone of no way home will
make for a good transition into doctor
strange too overall though the biggest
issue with the film is that it wasn't a
spider-man movie crossover events like
no way home while they excite audiences
and may just blow your mind they can
never truly tell a spider-man story
if you put all that to the side though
then you'll get an amazing crazy
action-packed film with tons of heart
for a list of all the craziest
spider-man stories we've ever seen in
television movies and comic books check
out this video also don't forget to
subscribe and like this video and from
everyone here at stream in the galaxy
thanks for watching
you